So the key here again is spacing.
I need you in the corner,
and if your man so much as looks my way,
then I’m going to get it to you.
Then I go up for three.
Yes.
But 'tis merely a pump fake!
No
I pull the ball down!
I step over the line.
No
I back down the big for
a contested fadeaway two from the elbow.
No. That’s exactly what you shouldn’t do
Chris, you know I can hit that shot over anybody
All day
It’s not about hitting shots
It’s about hitting EFFICIENT shots
Ugh, not you too with this efficiency fad
Whatever happened to the days when
knights would go one-on-one, mano-y-mano
in the paint, in a slow, grinding duel?
Melo...
if you want a role here on House Rockets
you must understand the system.
Study the analytics
I study plenty!
Carmelo, please
I remember when you used to be fun!
Whatever happened to Banana Boat Chris?
He learned how to win
And he wants to teach his friend,
so they can win together.
I want to win…it’s just…
it’s all so boring these days
Analytics, efficiency, defense...
Hm, you know what? Come with me.
I want to show you something
Whoa
Ah, Carmelo!
Welcome to the Johnson Spacing Center
Here, our Maesters test the frontiers of knowledge
to give House Rockets a competitive edge
What’s that?
Why, that’s our namesake. The rocket.
We value long-range weaponry here
House Rockets has never shied away from experimentation
Some produce incredible results
And others….
not so much.
What is this for?
Ah, that was Yao Ming’s chamber pot
Melo, have a look at this
What is that?
Those are moons orbiting another world
Makes you think...
you might not be the center of the universe after all
Huh, so you’re saying I’m just another planet?
No. He’s saying you are a moon
James Harden is the planet
Well, actually, Chris,
I am a star.
And stars should be STARters
Melo
...just needs a headband
And I’m gonna put a hoodie here
Melo, you’re not getting it—
You know, I bet the only reason I’m not starting
is because D’Antoni’s still bitter about New York.
No, no, no...
he’s just working off the Model
The Model?
It’s not possible
I can’t just shoot 30 threes a game
Look right here, James.
If the Model is correct, you could TRIPLE your offense
and pull us out of this slump
But what if I miss them?
I could go 0-for-27 myself!
Ah, but James…
what if you make them?
Aagh! What the— Carmelo?
What are you doing here?
Carmelo is interested in the Model
Really? Analytics? Melo?
OK...
This is the Model
We feed her data, and she gives us answers
untainted by human bias.
Huh, why does she have six arms?
...And four boobs?
Well, she was designed by a bunch of nerds who,
let’s just say...haven’t had too much experience
with the anatomy of a female
Carmelo, you have to understand this machine
it...doesn’t care about your feelings
The Model only knows pure analytics
If this thing truly knows basketball,
then I should have nothing to fear.
Show me how it works
These are your career stats. Let’s feed them in.
Hope she likes empty calories
OK. Model...
should Ser Carmelo be in the Hall of Fame?
Ah, look at that. First ballot
Brilliant.
Now, I want to know what my role here should be
May I?
Oh, uh, sure! Take it away
Model...
what should be my role on House Rockets?
He should’ve dunked that. He had the lane.
This Model is nothing but a hater!
How does this bloody thing even work?
Don’t, Carmelo
That’s where the computers are
Computers? What’s a computer?
Melo, don't—oh
The computers do all the calculations
needed to run the Model.
Oh, do they?
Well, do any of you even watch basketball?!
You don’t have a good VORP
W-why—what’s with their eyes?!
These poor souls witnessed
the dark ages of basketball in the early aughts.
The endless post plays. The long twos.
Ser Jordan on the Wizards
After a second Finals appearance by House Nets,
they couldn’t bear it any longer.
They gouged out their eyes
But on a positive note,
it turns out they’re perfect
for doing double-blinded analytics
Many became computers
The rest became referees
I don’t like your true shooting...
All right. Well, we really should get going, though.
You’re beginning to taint their judgment
Oh, you feel taller in person
Get off me!
Ser Carmelo, can you sign my abacus?
-No! I need to get out of here
-Nice boots! I like your boots
This is madness!
Well if you’d settle your emotional response,
you’d see it’s all quite logical, really.
No...no…this is all wrong
Your cold, heartless numbers
know nothing of my value
Anyone with eyes
can see the beauty of my game
A 10-time All-Star
behind PJ Tucker, really?
Marquese Chriss, actually—
Well I refuse to accept it, and I’ll never accept it!
Why did you even bring me here?!
Because you’re worth the risk…
at the veteran minimum
Carmelo, Lord Morey has given you a chance,
and it may be the only one you have left
Well, that’s ridiculous. I just need the ball.
I can still take any knight one-on-one!
Just give me the rock and I’ll—
Oh, what. C’mon, he f--ked me in New York
Hm...interesting
Oh, Seven Hells...Austin Rivers?
Kyle, wake up! Kyle! Kyle!
Norman? What are you doing?
Game of Zones. There's a new Game of Zones out.
A new Game of Zones?
Why didn't anyone tell me?
Well you just...you got to subscribe,
and they notify you...
Kawhi is already watching it!
They did Melo dirty